can we were in the head of digits
there's a few questions that have this
on the top identified the dependent and
independent variables okay think about
that again
what did dependent independent me in
this context very good like that's what
dependent means yeah that's right so
cost is the one that depends on time you
spend more time you'll have to pay more
money yeah does that make sense so
therefore I'm gonna label this as
dependent any dependent okay
that's pretty straight boy find the cost
for the plot for for a half hour so
where am I gonna go where am I gonna
look on this graph use some language
think about we have language for this
I've got two axes which one am i
interested in I'm interested in no
interesting way I mean we do tend to
call these the X and the y but they're
not x and y in your honor they're
actually late yeah it's the time axis
right so this horizontal time axis here
there's four and a half right there you
can see it between four and five so if I
draw my line up that looks like what I'm
going to what do you think that looks
like on the cost axis yeah good it's
clearly above 400 but less than 450 so I
think 425 pretty good so for Part B one
of the things you can write as well is
that like we don't actually know
precisely so I'm gonna put a squiggly
sign there which means approximate 425 I
think is gonna be certainly that looks
pretty good
Pudsey find let me uncover it find the
number of hours worked if the charge is
$250 so now our looking which access
yeah because that's just a vertical one
now we do tend to call why we usually
label that but it's not the y-axis here
so we want to use the right language for
the right question 250 where's that
that's yeah okay so again I'm gonna read
across
right so it looks to me like that that
really conveniently is going to go right
on to this last number here that's a bit
of a coincidence there's lots of numbers
well supposed to do it that's okay
Part C reading over time how many hours
now these are starts to get tricky and
we need to make a bit more of a choice
we're trying to find the gradient now
okay now when you have a look at this
again you gotta be careful you want to
choose the furthest point apart possible
do you remember the last lesson why have
you talked about further up is better
yeah very good like if I choose for
example these two points here right you
can see for this one we had to estimate
and if I were right next to it for this
one we would also have to estimate now
that estimate is good there no problems
but if that estimates off just a little
bit a whole grain it would be out of
line okay so in fact this time I'm going
to choose a couple of values that are
going to make a later question easier
and they're harder to read but we'll
still get an accurate result I want to
go right for the very end and for the
very beginning okay because they're the
furthest possible points I can choose so
I should be reasonably accurate so I'm
gonna go for listen you might want to
write this down with me that it's rise
over run so you remember which numbers
go where on the numerator if I go for
the furthest number how high is that
vertically
looks like 700 like because he's 600 and
it goes to all that okay so 700 I'm
gonna take away where I started from
okay you'd have a look what do you
reckon hmm now it does look like there's
the 50 lining and it looks like it's
just gone under that I'm gonna say 40 I
know that's probably not gonna be
exactly to be close enough and over the
size of the whole graph I think us to be
reasonably accurate now I define okay
the run he's one of the convenient
things about choosing this is zero right
I'm gonna take away zero that's an easy
number I don't have to like try and
estimate that it's exactly zero where am
I gonna end what would you call the nd
so yeah I've got I've got seven here
I've got eight here so it's between
seven and a half a day I think seven and
seven point seven five seven three
quarters that's pretty good okay so I'm
gonna write seven point seven five okay
yeah I'll calculate or make mitzvah'd of
this right it's gonna give us some
reader decimal what are we gonna get off
of this can someone get a number for me
and give me some decimal places too
maybe 5.12 seeks nothing about yeah now
I think we can see as you say before
right
that 0.1 seats hanging off the end
that's like the little era that we
introduced just because of Heller
measuring I'd be pretty happy to say
that's gonna be 85 now I've done the
first half the question but look again
at what it's asking us what do we
actually want it says finally what is
its meaning in this context yeah so
what's happening is um Reiser Iran means
how much are you writing how much is
costs going on every time you run one
unit that's one hour right so that's how
many dollars each hour each hour costs
about $85 so I'm gonna say that's $85 an
hour okay that's how much this plumbers
actually charge us and how we interpret
the gradient
okay now the handy thing about doing
great in that way is when you have a
good party
I know if you can make it up we've
already answered this question it says
finally intercept on the vertical axis
right this one what is that number we
already read it off it's 40 right
here's that number right there we used
it in the previous part that's the
vertical in stone but what does it mean
the gradient is cost per hour
what's the vertical assembly it means
yeah before before he has done anything
like he's been there for 0.1 seconds or
something and you've already been
charged
40 bucks we have a name for this if you
have a servicemen come up we call it a
corner charge right it's like before
I've touched anything you've called me
up it's taken you time to drive there I
could be doing another job right now so
you owe me some money so I would call
that this body a $40
charge can anyone else think of any
other context where it's like before you
spend any time doing it they just teach
you with a charge straight away like the
second that you start off ending on the
air in life - yeah taxis now we texting
this is actually worth writing down
maybe a different color because it
doesn't refer to this question but in
taxis this has a special name it's cold
and I want you to write it down so that
you recognize it
it's called flag for who's heard the
phrase flag phone before yeah this is
where the phrase hey can you flag a taxi
comes from right now I kind of I wait
and look this up because I was cues you
guys know a more excuse of that name
I always thought oh you're flagging a
taxi because how do you physically flag
a taxi that you waive your honor might
kind of like flag that's why the point
admit but I researched it actually it's
a different it's up sure what is sitting
inside a taxi
I can't I don't know if you can make
that out let me get the lights okay have
a look at that use your user invested
new skills what is this thing it's a
it's a taxi meter it's it's working out
how much they're charging right in fact
if you squint you can kind of see down
the bottom here right there is I'm how
many trips this person's done and these
kinds of numbers they're ticking over
the firm you drive or mom you sit in
traffic they're charging you one more
let me come back
look at this big like the whole thing
right see this thing up here this is the
flag that flagpole is their doctor right
so there's a taxi it's driving along and
you can see that actually usually lit up
right and this this is sitting right in
the front of the taxes so you can see at
a glance if you're standing on the side
of the road hey there's no one in that
taxi even if it's dark I can see so I'm
gonna get that taxi you get in and what
do you think the taxi driver does they
don't want anyone to think that the tax
is vacant so they take this and they
push it down and the flag it it follows
switches why it's called flag home okay
now that idea and that word has been
carried on into I mean now not so much
but back in the day when like coals were
individually charged with one more
expensive let's say the second you
connect to someone they charge you flag
for flag has everything to do with this
but even so this is a very old-fashioned
one as you can probably tell they don't
do this anymore
they've got fancy electrodes I just
connect straight to your donor but
anyway that's where it comes from and
that's that phrase flag hail you'll see
it in questions they'll say calculate
the flagpole and blah blah blah and
they're looking for you to work out what
that intercept is that's where it starts
charging you